Welcome back to Mental Fitness. We're gonna talk about goal setting this week.
Goal setting is such an important part of accomplishing our tasks and our goals
and our writing. Whether it's small or large, goal setting is such an important
tool to use intentionally. So get your notebooks out and get writing as we're
gonna set some goals for this year. No matter if you're setting long-term or
short-term goals, big or small goals, you want to ask yourself some questions
about them so that your mindset is in the right space to accomplish them.
Firstly, we want to ask ourselves why are we motivated to accomplish this goal.
Write down your reasons why the goal is a must and summarize it into two
sentences so that you can memorize it and keep it in your mind at all times. In
order to accomplish something, it needs to be on the front of our mind. Next, we
want to envision our outcome. I want you to close your eyes and actually envision
exactly how it would feel, how it looks, who is there when the goal is
accomplished. And I want you to write down your ideal outcome for the
situation or the goal. Whether it's very small and just for today or very large
and it's going to take multiple years, write it down and be very specific. Who
is involved, what people are involved, what resources are involved, and envision
it to its fullest extent. Now you're ready to start planning for your goal. So
first of all, give yourself a time frame, an exact time frame, a deadline and stick
to it with no excuses. This is the most important part of the planning stage of
goal setting. Make sure you give yourself a deadline. Write it down and put it
wherever you need to in your house, on your devices, and make sure you
accomplish a portion of that goal by that date exactly the way that you set
out to do. Write your why at the top of the plan so that you know where your
motivation is coming from and you'll have the energy to complete the task. Be
very specific with your planning. What will you be doing daily to accomplish
this goal? Who will be involved? What are their exact roles? How much exact money
do you need? How much exact time do you need? How much exact energy do you need?
Write this all down and be very specific to each goal. Like I said, even if it's a
daily goal, if it's a yearly goal, if it's a monthly goal, write it down and be
very specific. The more we dwell on the things that are going to bring us life,
the more life will come into our life. The journey of a thousand miles starts
with one step. So step every single day. You have a categorized list here. Start
with your why. Get a good vision and plan to get there.